grazie
tutti allora io ho 15
per provare a raccontarvi di una di una
guerra
ecco vi racconterò di una guerra non di
una guerra di quelle che tragicamente
vediamo in televisione nei telegiornali
o che quando ci colleghiamo a internet
anche in questi giorni così convulse e
strani del nostro tempo
ma la guerra di cui vi parlo io è una
guerra impalpabile una guerra una guerra
dell'immaginario una guerra che è
considerata una delle più antiche guerre
che sta attraversando l'umanità e che
tuttora attraversa è una guerra che si
svolge da migliaia di anni
fuori di noi dentro di noi ci attraversa
e come tutte le guerre per fortuna non
produce morti feriti profughi
distruzioni però produce cambiamenti
radicali del nostro modo di concepire la
realtà la guerra di cui vi voglio
parlare e la guerra tra l'immagine e la
scrittura
in realtà c'è un contenzioso attorno a
questa guerra cioè che cosa per cosa si
combatte si combatte per quella che è la
risorsa importante dell'umanità
cioè il controllo del linguaggio la
risorsa più importante l'umanità non è
loro non è il petrolio e il linguaggio
cioè la nostra capacità di essere
relazionali l'uno e l'altro è di dare
soprattutto un senso al nostro essere
nel mondo un grande poeta e scrittore
del novecento gottfried benn diceva
sempre ai suoi allievi
ciò che non esprime te non esiste
noi esistiamo in funzione di ciò che
siamo in grado di esprimere attraverso
il linguaggio verbale e gestuale noi in
realtà diamo forma al mondo il mondo
prende forma proprio da ciò che noi
siamo in grado di trasmettere è un po
quello che sta avvenendo qui tra noi io
sono da questa parte parlo voi ascoltate
ma in realtà si costruisce una relazione
proprio attraverso questo linguaggio che
è fatto di jessica è fatto di immagini
che è fatto di parole che è fatto di
sensazioni e liberamente si costruisce
il senso della realtà
che io proverò a trasmettervi e che voi
con assoluta tranquillità potete pensare
di accettare o rifiutare con
consapevolezza di essere voi stessi
portatori di un linguaggio e questo è il
motivo per cui per esempio quando nasce
un bambino
la prima cosa che fanno i genitori papà
la mamma genitori e da renault lui un
nome anzi fin dal momento del
concepimento quando è già un essere
vivente perché in quell atto in quel
nome c'è la sua stessa anima c'è un
pezzo di lui c'è la sua capacità già di
essere nel mondo
quindi il controllo del linguaggio è
fondamentale perché chi controlla il
linguaggio controlla poi il vero potere
del nostro mondo allora dicevamo di
questa guerra questa guerra nasce in
realtà migliaia di anni fa
2500 anni fa in una strana non
conosciuta zona precisa della jonia un
oscuro e sconosciuto inventore greco e
poi spiegherò perché uso il termine
inventore crea il cosiddetto alfa bella
scrittura alfabetica la scrittura ed
esisteva già da migliaia di anni in
mesopotamia nel semi la avanti cristo
già esistevano le prime forme di
scrittura ideografica e pittografica che
poi si stilizza in quello che noi oggi
chiamiamo il cuneiforme che erano le
prime forme di sperimentazione di
scrittura fonetica e geroglifici egizi
in cina in india
c'erano diverse forme di scrittura ma in
realtà 2500 anni fa in grecia che la
scrittura diventa uno strumento a tutti
gli effetti capace di riprodurre
interamente il linguaggio la scrittura
diventa lo strumento vero del linguaggio
la scrittura alfabetica greca che cosa
comporta questa comporta che ci troviamo
di fronte all'introduzione di una delle
più stravolgenti tecnologie innovative
che mai la storia abbia conosciuto
lui era platone e platone definisce in
un mito molto divertente in cui immagina
che un dio egizio che si chiamava tout
consegna questa invenzione all'allora
faraone amenofi dicendogli faraone io ti
do questo
un'invenzione straordinaria per il tuo
regno la scrittura con questa il più
riuscirai a far progredire il egitto
fino a diventare una potenza mondiale e
nel racconto di platone il faraone si
arrabbia dice ma ma che diavolo mi hai
dato
ma cosa ci faccio con questa roba questa
invenzione la scrittura è
pericolosissima perché farà perdere la
memoria all'uomo la capacita di
ricordare una realtà importante platone
perché la definisce esattamente così una
tecné cioè una tecnologia oggi la che
avremo la scrittura e la prima
tecnologia della comunicazione e perché
è importante l'introduzione di questa
tecnologia perché cambia radicalmente il
mondo
fino ad allora la trasmissione della
conoscenza e del sapere era
fondamentalmente concentrata sulla
costruzione per immagini e sulla
trasmissione orale della conoscenza
c'erano i grandi miti c'era la visione
ciclica della storia c'era la capacità
di dare all'immagine che ha in sé la
parola magia e il mago il ruolo di
trasformazione della realtà il ruolo di
dominio del linguaggio ed il senso di
dare al mondo in cui noi viviamo
quando viene introdotta questa
innovazione tecnologica improvvisamente
certo è un improvvisamente molto lento
nei secoli la società cambia perché ogni
volta che viene introdotta una nuova
tecnologia
questa tecnologia non è mai neutra non
arriva mai su un terreno che è
praticamente la assorbe in maniera
neutrale
ogni innovazione tecnologica cambia
radicalmente non solo
l'organizzazione della società ma anche
il nostro sistema neuronale anche la
nostra capacità di percepire la realtà
che cambia proprio in funzione dei nuovi
strumenti tecnologici che vengono
introdotti e in effetti la scrittura fa
esattamente questo
nel corso dei secoli fa una serie di
modifiche che alterano totalmente la
nostra percezione della realtà ma anche
il modo stesso in cui organizziamo la
conoscenza ma anche l'organizzazione
stessa della della società modifica le
prove le pratiche di memoria di
organizzazione della memoria
separa il testo dal contesto fissa il
contenuto rendendoli mutato riorganizza
la società compaiono delle figure
sociali che prima non esistevano oggi le
chiameremo un'elite tecnocratica quella
degli script ma ad esempio cioè coloro
che erano avevano in dote la conoscenza
di questa tecnologia e quindi la
potevano trasmettere la scrittura un
patto nei secoli molto importante perché
è attraverso la scrittura che si supera
una dimensione fortemente concentrata
sull'immagine l'immagine come strumento
di conoscenza e la conosce è anche la
comunicazione orale vengono un po messi
da parte
la scrittura che nasce come uno
strumento di archiviazione come uno
strumento di organizzazione della
società inizia a essere riproducendo il
linguaggio anche lo strumento attraverso
cui si inizia fingere la realtà a
raccontarla a narrarla i primi racconti
finzionali dalla letteratura in poi
nascono proprio attraverso la scrittura
che non è un'invenzione di nuovi simboli
e la lo srotolamento di simboli grafici
che consentono alla voce di andare verso
una dimensione lineare e non è un caso
che la visione del mondo lineare e
inizia a svilupparsi esattamente dopo
l'invenzione della scrittura
per secoli la scrittura contende con
l'immagine il dominio della conoscenza
del sapere e anche lo strumento di
diffusione del linguaggio
poi ci sarà un momento in cui la
scrittura prende il sopravvento in
questa guerra eterna tra due forme
diciamo di di espressione e di dominio
del linguaggio e avviene in modo
particolare nel 1450 conclude quando con
l'invenzione della stampa a caratteri
mobili di fatto la scrittura diventa
dominatrice sull'immagine e l'immagine
viene più o meno relegata in aspetti non
marginali ma insomma secondari della
società la trasmissione della conoscenza
e del sapere viene quasi tutta
concentrata attraverso il modo di
diffusione del libro stampato che
diffonde tra l'altro anche gli strumenti
di accesso a questa tecnologia
è una storia lunga lenta questa
complessa perché studia la storia della
comunicazione su come gli strumenti
legati all'immagine e gli strumenti
legati alla scrittura abbiano in qualche
modo conteso il dominio del linguaggio e
quindi anche della visione della realtà
ci sarà un salto notevole per motivi di
tempo ovviamente lo abbreviamo che ci
porterà direttamente nell'ottocento
quando nuove innovazioni tecnologiche
quando altre invenzioni straordinarie
fatte da questi uomini austeri questi
signori con barbe varie introducono i
mezzi di comunicazione elettrici che
cosa succede che a un certo punto la
scrittura rimane ancora centrale nel
processo di trasmissione della
comunicazione del linguaggio e della
conoscenza ma iniziano a essere
introdotti degli strumenti importanti in
cui la tecnologia esposta la dimensione
dalla scrittura a un livello sensoriale
altro in questo caso per esempio
partendo dal suono la possibilità di
trasmettere a distanza la voce fino ad
arrivare a l'invenzione della fotografia
che segna il punto di partenza del nuovo
riscatto dell'immagine sulla scrittura
la possibilità attraverso uno strumento
tecnico di produrre delle immagini e
trasferirle fuori da noi stessi
fissandole da una parte modifica non
solo il modo di trasmissione della
memoria quindi della conoscenza del
linguaggio ma anche il nostro modo di
percepire la realtà il punto di arrivo
spaventoso e straordinario di questo è
con loro due con i fratelli lumiere con
loro e con l'invenzione del cinema qui
ci sarà se parte un video molto
divertente perché qui da questo video
qui nasce la storia del cinema è un
video che fratelli un ieri girano
filmando i loro operai che escono dalla
loro fabbrica di lione
e viene sempre da domandarsi che impatto
può avere avuto questa invenzione che
per noi è ormai assolutamente normale
quasi banale perché noi viviamo
all'interno del dei media pervasivi di
quel sistema di controllo dell'immagine
che oggi fa entrare addirittura noi
nello schermo ma quale sensazione
possono avere avuto quegli uomini eppure
donne di fine ottocento nel vedere se
stessi proiettati fuori da se stesse
perché ogni innovazione tecnologica
modifica la percezione della realtà e
questo è il punto eclatante attraverso
cui l'immagine ritorna vincente sempre
più sulla scrittura
oggi noi viviamo nel mondo delle
immagini dal cinema passi in avanti ce
ne sono stati tanti e arrivata a un
certo punto la televisione che ha
consentito all'immagine di diventare
casalinga cioè di essere fruita in
maniera quasi familiare la televisione
nella sua poi evoluzione da televisione
in bianco e nero da televisione a colori
diventa l'epicentro della cultura
diventa lo strumento su cui si fonda la
cultura di massa
questo episodio è molto queste foto le
ho messe perché sanno che se avete
interessanti per capire come anche il
potere politico e anche l'organizzazione
delle moderne democrazie si rimettono in
discussione proprio attraverso
l'immagine qui siamo nel 26 settembre
del 1960 e questo è il primo dibattito
politico televisivo nella storia delle
presidenziali americane un giovane
richard nixon candidato repubblicano il
conservatore fronteggia un giovane john
fitzgerald kennedy e il mondo della
guerra fredda con il mondo della grande
tensione queste elezioni americane sono
importantissime ma sono le prime
attraverso cui gli americani
sceglieranno il loro presidente con la
televisione ci sono molti aneddoti su
questo dibattito televisivo che un pezzo
della storia della televisione di tutti
i tempi ma un racconto va fatto e cioè
che il povero richard nixon tra i tanti
aneddoti che si raccontano nei giorni
precedenti a questo dibattito aveva
avuto un influenza virale quindi stava
malissimo molto
molto male non c'era andato
particolarmente preparato e non aveva
compreso la potenza del mezzo
fateci caso kennedy è vestito di scuro
su sfondo grigio nixon si è vestito di
grigio su sfondo grigio ma in realtà
in tutto questo dibattito knicks non
farà altro che sudare perché il virus
era ancora in corso e questa immagine
qua segnerà la sconfitta di richard
nixon e il dibattito verrà stravinto da
kennedy kennedy vince per la sua
immagine straordinariamente forte e
convincente
il povero nixon sudato che cerca di
asciugare il sudore sarà deleterio per
la scelta finale del del popolo
americano
da questo momento in poi di storia ne
passa tanta oggi l'immagine diventa
sensoriale il dominio dell'immagine
arrivata al punto da scardinare il
famoso treno dei fratelli lumiere
secondo cui la leggenda quando fu
proiettato gli spettatori fuggirono dal
cinema spaventati nel fatto che il treno
potesse arrivare e poi l'ultima
questione che è vera mano al
castelgrande sociologo della
comunicazione dice che i media non sono
più il quarto potere sono il luogo dove
si sviluppa il potere in realtà
l'immagine oggi è lo strumento
attraverso cui si gestisce linguaggio
chi controlla l'immagine oggi
probabilmente in grado di controllare il
potere il demiurgo dell'immagine in
tutte le loro forme narrative ed
espressive hanno una straordinaria
responsabilita per mantenere in vita gli
spazi di pluralismo perché ogni immagine
oggettivizza la realtà la scrittura no
la soggettività e per questo che bisogna
avere cura nella comunicazione dei video
e cura nelle forme espressive artistiche
date dalle immagini e senso di
responsabilità perché il dominio di
questa roba interessa tutti quanti noi
grazie
[Applauso]